[ Music ]
JEAN-FRANCOIS BILODEAU:
Have you ever set a SIEM,
connected a few data
sources, and still felt
like you were operating
with blind spots?
Missing key signals,
chasing incomplete alerts,
and spending too much time
normalizing data instead
of investigating threats.
The difference between
reactive security operation
and a confidence one often
comes down to one thing,
getting the right data in,
in the right shape,
at the right time.
Let me introduce you to a
session where you learn how
to tackle these
real-world scenarios
by connecting the data sources
that makes Microsoft
Sentinel truly effective.
Hello and welcome.
We're glad you've joined us.
I'm Jean-Francois Bilodeau, a
Microsoft Technical Trainer.
In this session, we'll
cover for Learning Path 8,
Connecting Data Source to
Microsoft Sentinel SIEM.
Together, we'll walk through how
to manage and deploy content
in Microsoft Sentinel,
how data connectors work,
and how to bring in signals
from Microsoft Services,
Microsoft Defender XDR, Windows
Host, CAF-based appliances,
syslog sources, and
Threat Intelligence feed.
By the end, you'll know what
each connector path is for,
what prerequisite to plan for,
and what to expect in terms
of the data that lands
in your workspace.
So you can move
from we have logs
to we have actionable detection.
So let's get started
with this session.
Here we set the stage.
Defending against cyber threats
is a continuous operation,
and Microsoft Security
Operations Platform is designed
to help you collect signal,
correlate activities,
and respond faster.
In this learning path, the focus
is on connecting data sources
to Microsoft Sentinel.
That means understanding
the connector ecosystem
and making sure the
security signals you rely
on across cloud,
identity, endpoints,
and third-party appliances
are flowing into your scene
in a consistent and usable way.
Let's take a look at
what we'll cover.
We'll start by managing
content in Microsoft Sentinel,
then we'll connect data to
Sentinel using data connectors,
including Microsoft Services
and Microsoft Defender XDR.
From there, we'll walk through
connecting Windows hosts,
bringing in common event
format logs, connecting syslog
from Linux-based
sources, and finally,
connecting threat indicators
so you're detection can match,
again, known bad
infrastructure and entities.
Here, we begin with a key idea.
Sentinel isn't just a
place where logs land.
It's a place where you
manage security content,
things like rules,
workbooks, and playbooks
that turn those logs into
detection and response action.
After completing this module,
you'll be able to do two things.
First, you'll be able to use
solutions from the Content Hub
to quickly bring in
Microsoft-provided
and partner-provided content.
Second, you'll be able
to connect repositories
so you can deploy
and manage content
through source
control workflows.
Let's take a look at what
a Content Hub solution
can include.
A single solution may bring in
data connectors to ingest data,
parsers to normalize it,
workbooks for visualization,
and analytics rule
for detection.
You can also get hunting queries
for proactive investigation,
notebooks for advanced analysis,
watch lists for enrichment
and correlation, and playbook,
plus Azure Logic App
custom connectors
to automate responses
and workflows.
When you create custom
content, you can store
and manage it directly inside
your Sentinel workspace,
or you can manage it
in an external source
control repository,
commonly GitHub or Azure DevOps.
Managing content in an external
repository is powerful
because it lets you update that
content outside of Sentinel,
track changes with versioning,
and then automatically deploy
those updates in your workspace
as part of a controlled
release process.
Now we shift from managing
content to bringing data in.
The goal is to connect
your data source
to Microsoft Sentinel using
the right data connectors
so your workspace receives
the logs, alerts,
and telemetry needed
for detection,
hunting, and responses.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to explain how data connectors
are used in Microsoft Sentinel,
and you'll be able to describe
the different data connector
provider categories so you
can choose the right path
for each type of data source.
To collect log data in Sentinel,
you connect your data source
using Sentinel connectors.
In practice, you typically start
by installing the appropriate
Content Hub solutions
because that solution often
includes the data connector
you need.
And then you configure
that connector
so it can begin streaming
data in your workspace.
Here are the main categories
of data connector provider
you'll work with.
There are connectors for
Microsoft Defender XDR
and the related
Defender services.
There are connectors for
Microsoft Azure services.
There are also Windows
Security Event connectors,
commonly through the Azure
Monitoring Agent, or AMA.
You'll also see a broad
set of vendor connectors
and custom connectors,
which we'll detail next.
Finally, there's the Common
Event Format, or CAF connectors,
which is frequently used for
third-party security appliance
that can emit CAF over syslog.
Let's dig into
custom connectors.
You have several
approaches depending
on how much control you need
and how much development
effort you can invest.
Option includes the codeless
connector platform,
often called CCP, using
a lock stream plugin,
building integration with Logic
App, using Azure Function
for custom ingestion
and processing,
using Azure Monitor agent
for collection scenarios
or sending data via
the Log Analytic API.
The key here is to
select a method
that matches your source system,
your transformation need,
and your operational model.
Next, we'll focus on
connecting Microsoft Services.
These connectors help you
ingest high-value signal
from Microsoft security
and cloud service,
and in many cases, enable
streamlined incident creation
and investigation
workflows in Sentinel.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to connect Microsoft
Service data connectors,
explain how connectors can
automatically create incidents
in Microsoft Sentinel, and
activate the Microsoft Defender
for Cloud connector in Sentinel.
Before you turn these
connectors on, it's important
to plan prerequisite
and outcome.
For Microsoft
Defender for Cloud,
you'll need the write
permission on the workspace,
specifically read and
write permission.
Also, keep in mind
configuration detail.
For example, the Windows
Security Events via AMA
Connectors, Create Data
Connection Rule, or DCR.
And when we talk about incident
creation, a common pattern is
that incidents are created from
alert data, often specifically
from alert store in
security alert table.
So understanding where alerts
land helps you understand what
can drive incidents.
Let's take a look at Microsoft
Defender for Cloud integration.
There are two
connectors available.
The first is the
subscription-based Microsoft
Defender for Cloud, sometimes
labeled as the legacy connector.
This connector streams your
security alerts from Defender
for Cloud into Microsoft
Sentinel, specifically
into the security alert table.
The second option is the
tenant-based Microsoft Defender
for Cloud Connector.
This connector also streams
your security alerts
into the security alert
table in Sentinel,
but it can additionally stream
into Defender XDR
alerts and incidents.
So your operation
model includes working
in the Defender portal
as well as Sentinel.
The tenant-based
approach supports
that broader integration.
Here, we gain deeper insight
into Microsoft Entra ID
by connecting audit logs and
sign-in logs to Sentinel.
This helps you investigate
identity-focused scenarios,
like suspicious
sign-in patterns,
changes to privileged role,
or risky user activities,
using data that's
already central
to many incident investigations.
This is marked as an
optional topic, but it's one
of the most commonly deployed
connectors in real environments.
Beyond Identity and
Defender for Cloud,
there are many
Azure-focused solutions
that include data connectors.
Common examples include
user activity logs,
Azure DDoS Protection, Azure
Firewall, Azure Key Vault,
Azure SQL Database, Azure Web
Application Firewall, or WAF.
These connectors
give you visibility
into control plane
action, network control,
and data layer events signals
that are often essential
for cloud threats and detection.
Next, we connect Microsoft
Defender XDR to Sentinel.
This integration helps you
bring in Defender signals and,
depending on configuration,
enable Sentinel to work
with Defender's alerting
and incident ecosystem
more seamlessly.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to activate the Microsoft
Defender XDR connector
in Sentinel.
To enable it, you typically
need security administrator
permission in the tenant
for Microsoft Entra ID.
In many environments, this
is enabled by default
when Sentinel is onboarded
to Defender XDR.
And if you onboard Sentinel
to the Defender portal
and you're licensed
for Defender XDR,
the connection is
automatically established,
and the data connector
is set up for you.
When planning
Defender-based connector,
you'll commonly use Microsoft
Defender XDR, Microsoft Defender
for Office 365, and Microsoft
Defender for Endpoint.
A key point to emphasize here is
that these Defender connectors
generally send alert data
into Sentinel, and that
alert data can then be used
to generate incident, depending
on how you configure
incident creation role
and how you want
your SOC to operate.
Let's take a look at what
the Microsoft Defender XDR
Connector provides.
It's installed as part of the
Microsoft Defender XDR solution
and lets you stream
advanced hunting data.
It's also helpful to
remember what's included
in the Defender XDR Suite,
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint,
Defender for Identity,
Defender for Office 365,
Defender for Cloud
App, Defender Alert,
Defender Vulnerability
Management, Microsoft Purview,
Data Loss Prevention, and
Microsoft Entra ID Protection.
Once connected, you can expect
a wide range of data types
to become available, including
core incidents and alert tables
like security incident
and security alerts,
plus a broad set of hunting
and telemetry tables,
such as device events,
device file events,
device info, and many more.
In addition to the major
Defender workload,
Sentinel provides
built-in connectors
for other Microsoft
Defender solutions.
Examples include Microsoft
Defender for Threat Intelligence
and Microsoft Defender for IoT.
These connectors broaden
your visibility,
bringing in intelligence context
and operational
technology signal
where those are part
of your environment.
Now, let's focus
on Windows host.
Endpoint and server security
events remain foundational
for investigation,
so the goal here is
to connect both Azure-based
and non-Azure Windows machine
so that their security
events can be collected
and analyzed in Sentinel.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to connect Azure Windows
Virtual Machine to Sentinel,
connect non-Azure Windows
host to Sentinel,
and configure the
Azure Monitoring Agent
to collect security events.
When you plan Windows
Security event ingestion,
you'll typically use the
Content Hub solutions
as part of your entry point.
Common solution includes the
Windows Security events via AMA,
Windows Server DNS via AMA,
and Windows forwarded events.
These solutions install the
required data connector
from the Azure Monitoring Agent
and uses Data Collection Rules,
DCR, to define what
gets collected.
And just as a quick reminder,
AMA stands for Azure
Monitoring Agent.
Here we look at the Windows
security events via AMA
connector and why it's
commonly recommended.
Benefits include being able
to manage collection settings
at scale, reusing the
Azure Monitoring Agent
across multiple solutions,
improving security
and performance,
and saving costs
by using the Data
Collection Rule.
There are also limitations
to be aware of.
Some features may be available
only in public preview.
In terms of requirement,
you'll be working with DCR,
and for non-Azure VMs or device,
you'll typically need Azure Arc.
Let's take a look
at what it looks
like when you install this
from the Content Hub.
You'll install the Windows
security events via AMA
connector solution,
review the prerequisite,
and then configure collection
through a data collection role.
Now we focus on
selecting the resources
that the DCR will apply to.
For non-Azure machine, they must
be connected through Azure Arc,
and when you add machine,
add DCR resources,
any machine that doesn't already
have an Azure Monitoring Agent,
whether it's Windows or Linux,
will have the agent installed
as part of that
onboarding process.
Here, we examine the DCR
configuration itself.
This is where you
specify exactly
which Window Security
event to collect
and how they should be
delivered into your workspace,
giving you centralized
control over volume, cost,
and investigative value.
Next, let's bring in log
from external security solution
using the Common Event Format,
or CAF.
This is a common scenario where
you're integrating network,
firewall, or third-party
security appliances data
into Sentinel.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to explain the CAF connector
deployment option in Sentinel,
and you'll be able to explain
the difference between the CAF
and Syslog connector, so you
can choose the right approach
for your source system and for
the level of parsing you need.
Here's the typical deployment
model for CAF ingestion.
You deploy a syslog forwarder
server that acts as a bridge
between your appliance
and Sentinel.
That forwarder is a
dedicated Linux machine
with the Azure Monitoring
Agent for Linux installed.
Many vendor-specific
Sentinel connectors rely
on the CAF connectors
behind the scene.
You can deploy this forwarder
in Azure or on-premise,
and importantly, CAF is
generally recommended
over basic syslog because CAF
provides parse message data,
which reduces the amount
of parsing you need
to do during queries
and investigation.
This architecture diagram
illustrates how CAF logs
collection data using the
common event format using AMA
connectors currently in preview.
Your security appliance sends
syslog to the forwarder.
The forwarder uses
its syslog daemon
and the Azure monitoring
agent for Linux to collect
and securely send those
events to Sentinel,
where they're parsed and
enriched for analysis.
Let's walk through the
connection process.
You start by creating
a Data Collection Rule
and then use the link on the
connector page to get a script.
You run that script on the
designated Linux machine
that will act as your forwarder.
That machine can be physical
or virtual, could be on-prem,
in Azure, or another cloud,
as long as it can receive
the syslog traffic
from your security solution.
When you run the script,
it installs the Azure
Monitoring Agent for Linux
and configures it to
listen to CAF messages
from the built-in Linux
syslog daemon running
on TCP port 25226.
It also configures secure
transport over TLS
to your Sentinel workspace,
where the messages are
parsed and enriched.
At the same time, the script
configures the syslog daemon,
such as rsyslog or syslog-ng,
to listen to syslog messages
from your security
solution on TCP port 514
and then forwards only the
messages identified as CAF
to the agent locally
on TCP port 25226.
Now, let's move to
syslog ingestion.
While CAF is a structured format
layered on top of syslog,
many environments still need to
connect to plain syslog events
from Linux hosts and
appliance and then parse them
as needed into Sentinel.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to describe the Syslog Data
Collection Rule configuration
in Microsoft Azure, understand
how the Azure Monitoring Agent
for Linux is deployed, create
and configure a DCR to send data
to Sentinel, and create a
parser using KQL in Sentinel.
And that will reinforce
that creating
and configuring the DCR
is the central step
that ties collection
to your workspace.
Here's the overall approach.
You stream events from your
Linux-based syslog supporting
machine or appliances
into Sentinel using the Azure
Monitoring Agent for Linux
and Data Collection Rules.
The host native syslog
daemon collects local event
of specified type and forwards
them locally to the agent,
and the agent streams them to
your log analytic workspace.
From a how it works perspective,
syslog is a common Linux
event logging protocol
where the Azure monitoring
agent for Linux is installed.
It configures the local syslog
daemon to forward message
to the agent on TCP port 28330.
The agent then sends
those messages
to your log analytic workspace
over TCP 443 using HTTPS.
Once ingested, the events
are parsed into entries
in the syslog table, which
you can query using Sentinel
under logs.
This diagram shows the syslog
collection architecture
from a single source.
The key takeaway is the flow.
Source generates syslogs.
The agent and local daemon
cooperate to forward events,
and the workspace receives
and stores those events
for Sentinel queries
and detection.
Here we focus on onboarding
Azure Linux Virtual Machine.
When you add Azure
Linux VM as resources
in Syslog Data Collection Rule,
the Azure monitoring
agent is deployed.
So to connect an
Azure based Linux VM,
you add it as a DCR resource,
and the platform handles agent
deployment and association
so events can start flowing.
For non-Azure Linux host, the
approach changes slightly.
You provision those
machines using Azure Arc.
There are more steps involved
compared to Azure Native VM,
and you generally need to
manually install the agent
as part of bringing that
host under management
so it can participate in
DCR-based collection.
Now we configure what
actually gets collected.
The Data Collection Rule
will only collect events
that match the facilities
and severities you specify.
This is a critical
control point.
It lets you balance
investigative coverage
with data volume and
cost, while ensuring
that the event you do ingest
are the ones your detection
and hunting workflow
actually need.
Let's dive deeper into how
syslog data is parsed once
it's ingested.
The syslog connector writes
events into the syslog table,
and unlike the CAF connector,
the message payload is stored
as a single string in the
syslog message field.
That means parsing is something
you must do manually,
you must handle.
One effective approach is
to create a reusable
parser using KQL.
In this example, a function
name MyParser is created.
The query starts from
the syslog table,
filters on a specific
process name such as squid,
and then uses the
extract statement
to pull structured field
from the raw syslog
message text field
like URL source IP address,
username, RemotePort,
and domains are extracted
and made available
as individual columns.
By saving this query as a
function, you only need
to write the parsing logic once.
After that, you can
refer MyParser just
like any other
table in Sentinel.
In practice, you create the
query in the log experience,
select "Save,"
choose "Function,"
and then assign a
function name and alias.
From that point forward, calling
MyParser gives you consistently
parse syslog data without
repeating the parsing logic
in every query.
Next, we shift focus to
Threat Intelligence.
Dissecting threat
indicator allows Sentinel
to match law data against known
malicious IPs, domains, URL,
and file hashes,
turning raw telemetry
into actionable detection.
This capability help
bridges the gap
between external intelligence
and internal telemetry,
enabling detection
that are informed
by what's happening beyond
your own environment.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to install the Threat
Intelligence Content Hub
solution, configure Threat
Intelligence Connector,
use analytic rules, hunting
queries, and workbook,
and view threat indicators
in Sentinel logs
through the Threat
Intel indicator table.
These skills are foundational
for enriching detection
with external context
and improving
investigation efficiency.
Here we outline what the Threat
Intelligence solution provides.
It includes multiple
data connectors
such as TAXII-based feed,
the Threat Intelligence
Upload Indicator API,
Microsoft Defender Threat
Intelligence, and integration
with third-party Threat
Intelligence platform.
Analytics rules use these
indicators to generate alerts
and incidents where match
occurs in your log data.
Workbook summarizes indicator
activities and trends,
while hunting queries allows
analysts to proactively search
for related activities.
Together, these components
help operationalize Threat
Intelligence within Sentinel.
Installing the Threat
Intelligence solution
from the Content Hub
gives you access
to five built-in connectors.
These include Connector for
Threat Intelligence Platform,
the Upload Indicator API,
Microsoft Defender
Threat Intelligence,
Premium Microsoft Defender
and TAXII feeds.
Once installed, these
connectors make it possible
to ingest indicators from
multiple sources into Sentinel
in a standardized way.
With indicators flowing in, the
next step is enabling detection.
Threat Intelligence analytic
rule template allows you
to create alerts and incident
when log event matches
known indicator.
By enabling and tuning
these templates,
Sentinel can automatically
service activities that align
with known malicious
infrastructure helping analysts
focus on high-confidence
threats.
In addition to
built-in connectors,
you can also send
indicators directly
to Sentinel using the
Upload Indicators API.
This allows application or
Threat Intelligence platform
to push indicators in Sentinel
using REST-based method.
This approach is commonly used
when integrating custom tooling
or centralizing Threat
Intelligence platforms
that already manage
indicator lifecycle.
Once indicators are ingested,
they're available
in multiple places.
You can view them directly in
the Threat Intelligence Blade
or query them from the Threat
Intel Indicator table in Logs.
At this point in the session,
everything comes together.
This demonstration shows how
logs are connected to Sentinel
across multiple sources,
reinforcing how connectors,
Data Collection Rules,
and Content Hub solution
work together in practice.
In this demo, let's
start connecting data
to our Sentinel using
Data Connector.
We've already got our Sentinel
workspace open over here.
Let's navigate to the
Content Management Hub.
Let's select the Content Hub.
And what we're going to do
over here is we're going
to connect Microsoft
Defender for Cloud.
Let's search for it,
It's already installed
but not configured.
So let's select it.
And let's go down to "Manage."
Here are our connectors.
Let's select the
subscription-based Defender.
Let's configure it.
And let's scroll down.
What we're going to do here is
connect it to our subscription.
All I need to do is select
a subscription, connect it,
and optionally choose
whether we want
to enable bi-directional
sync between Sentinel
and Defender for Cloud.
Done. We have connected Defender
for Cloud with Sentinel.
We can see status connected.
Next, let's connect an Azure
Activity data to Sentinel.
We'll go back to
our content hub.
Let's search for Azure Activity.
Let's select it,
click on "Manage."
Let's select the Azure Activity
Connector, open connector page
so we can do the configuration.
And let's scroll down.
We're not going to be able
to do the full connection
because we need to grant access
to Sentinel to Azure Activity.
And to do that, we'll
set up a policy.
We'll do that at the
subscription level.
We're not going to
include everything.
We're going to connect our
log analytic workspace
to Azure activity.
Select. Remediation will let
Azure do the heavy lifting.
Create a remediation
task to ensure
that the connection
can take place.
For that connection
to take place,
identity will be necessary.
So in the next step, we're going
to select a managed identity
and launch the creation.
Now that this remediation
has taken place,
we can connect our Azure
Activity Log to Defender.
Next, let's connect virtual
machines to Sentinel.
We'll begin by creating
a virtual machine
in the Azure portal.
So let's go ahead and
create a new resource.
In this case, we're going
to create a Windows
11 virtual machine.
And let's pick, there we
go, Windows 11 Enterprise.
We'll go to slightly older
version, 23H2, and create.
We'll need to select a
subscription, resource group.
We'll pick an existing
resource group.
Let's give it a distinct name.
AZWin01. And where do
we want to run it?
We don't need
infrastructure redundancy.
Let's select an adequate
size for this one.
A d2s_v4 should be adequate.
And finally, username
and password
for the administrative account.
Let's just create a sample
administrative name, password,
strong password, of course,
and confirm that we have
an eligible license
for Windows 11
available on hand.
Let's launch the creation.
It'll take a moment or
two to create the VM.
Deploying a VM deploys
a lot of resources.
And there we go, we are done.
And now we've got our first
virtual machine deployed.
It's already got the Azure
Monitoring Agent installed,
so now we're ready to
connect it to Sentinel.
Let's do that next.
All right, back in Sentinel,
let's now connect our
virtual machine to Sentinel
so we can start receiving
security events.
We're going to head down
to the Content Hub.
And let's search for
Windows Security Events.
Let's find the connector.
There it is.
It's already installed, but
it needs to be configured.
Let's click on "Managed."
And we're going to connect
to our machine using Windows
Security Event via AMA,
Azure Monitoring Agent.
To do that, we're going to need
to create a Data
Collection Rule, DCR.
Let's go ahead and
do that right now.
Create Data Collection Rule.
We're going to give it a name.
Let's just call it AZWinDCR.
And the subscription, resource
group in which the machine
and the DCR will exist.
Next, which machine or
machines do we want to connect
to this Data Connection Rule?
In this case, we'll pick the VM
we've created just a moment ago.
Collect. We're going to pick
up every security event.
And next, create.
We've set up our Data
Collection Rule.
We've connected to the Azure
Monitoring Agent on that VM.
Now, Sentinel can
receive telemetry
from that virtual machine.
If needs be, we can change
the Data Collection Rule,
going back to the collector.
But let's refresh, make sure
that we can now see our
virtual machine in here.
There's the rule
that we've created.
Let's recap what we've covered
in this learning path.
Microsoft Sentinel provides a
wide range of data connectors
to bring in logs and alerts
from Microsoft services,
Defender solution,
Windows Analytics host,
third-party appliances, and
Threat Intelligence Source.
We explored how Content Hub
solution bundles connectors,
parsers, workbooks, analytics
rule, hunting queries,
notebooks, watch
lists, and playbook.
We also emphasized the role
of Data Collection Rule
in managing collection at
scale, improving performance,
and controlling costs.
Finally, we looked at
how Threat Intelligence
and Microsoft Defender
integration enhances detection
and investigation capabilities
across the platform.
This concludes our session.
There are many ways to complete
your learning journey.
We encourage you to watch other
videos in this course or search
for your next favorite topic on
Microsoft Learn at aka.ms/learn.